offering services every day to thousands
and even millions of people is an
amazing challenge from a scale
perspective more specifically take
workforce development programs run by
cities and states they are extremely
important and as they support so many
people with an array of services that
range from job matching opportunities
personal development via job coaching
self-service resources to just name a
few
and i have learned a lot about how
running such meaningful programs
requires extensive coordination across
applicants employers community partners
and sharing knowledge broadly
2020 brought many challenges especially
as in-person operations were shut down
and many were left vulnerable to
unemployment the state of rhode island
responded to these challenges by
modernizing their workforce development
operations and moving completely to an
online platform called the virtual
career center also nicknamed vcc
it was developed in partnership with
google cloud and a non-profit called
research improving people's lives and
the vcc was fully built by google cloud
partner mavenwave as a quick intro
mavenwave helps a wide array of
organizations including public sector
customers with many types of cloud
initiatives whether it's big data and
machine learning building mobile
applications helping design positive
online user experiences moving
infrastructure to the cloud or deploying
collaboration tools like email chat
documents they even offer strategy and
technology advice today i've invited
joel osmond from mavenwave to share more
about that journey howdy my friend mind
sharing a bit about what you do so i
lead the maven wave digital experience
design our ux and design team as well as
our custom application development
practice and i am also the executive
sponsor for our virtual career center
solution that we've been bringing to
market with google
joel for the folks watching could you
briefly share what was the specific use
case your team focused on so the primary
use case that we looked at is how can we
apply
leading-edge emerging technologies to
help people get back to work and to use
them those tools in such a way that we
can augment the personal one-to-one
interactions that these agencies have
been using with job seekers to help them
get back to work that's beautiful joel
can you touch upon some of the products
it took to build the virtual career
center the vcc it comprises a number of
different google technologies um
obviously the custom pieces that we're
building for scheduling for
login authentication for data pipelines
and data analytics are all in google
cloud platform and we're doing custom
builds there that integrate into the
state's existing systems so we
essentially have taken things like
google me
google calendar google docs a lot of
those core tool sets that people use in
their everyday lives we've wrapped them
in this specific use case around the
virtual career center so when a job
coach is is going online to to update
their availability of when they can held
sessions that's really happening in the
background in google calendar and when a
job seeker and a job coach get together
in a video session it's actually
happening in google meet so those are
really the the engines of technologies
if you will that are driving the entire
vcc experience now if you don't mind
let's do a quick walkthrough of what
i've learned about your architecture and
then i would like to talk a bit more
about some of the design decisions
behind all of this for starters end
users mainly interact via an app built
on angular as the front end and is
connected to backend services hosted on
google kubernetes engine or relevant
google workspace products such as chat
calendar meet drive and docs
from a user journey perspective there
are three main types of users at this
time and that's job coaches job seekers
and employers
job coaches all have google ids in the
google workspace domain and therefore
authenticate against the google identity
repository job seekers are authenticated
through a cognito-based process
maintained by the nonprofit i mentioned
earlier with the rhode island
infrastructure team and the department
of information technology for contacts
prior to the start of the vcc project
the state of rhode island was making use
of this cognito identity repository to
authenticate users going through the
unemployment insurance application
process and rather than adding an
additional identity repository for users
interacting with the state the decision
was made to leverage the existing
cognito repository and its methods of
authentication in this release of the
virtual career center employers
participate directly with google meet
and to an extent google calendar but not
the annular app
to touch upon some of the google cloud
components specifically let's start with
firestore which is a real-time database
that keeps data in sync across client
apps it is used as the primary
persistence tool for the web pages it
also has a small role to play with the
login process for job coaches
next is bigquery which is a serverless
warehouse for data which is why it is
used primarily for reporting purposes
data studio is used to build filterable
dashboards over it
then there are cloud functions which are
functions you can trigger via snippets
of code and are used for a few purposes
in the solution such as populating jobs
and training data in the production
instance ensuring consistency between
google calendar and availability data
for job coaches and for populating
bigquery on a scheduled basis
then there's the kubernetes cluster on
which server side code runs in a single
region deployment with a minimum of four
nodes per zone across three zones of the
u.s east region the cluster is set to
auto scale in order to ensure that there
is sufficient processing power in the
event that there are spikes in activity
on the site
from a security standpoint there's cloud
armor which protects applications and
websites from attacks and in this
specific implementation there are
several sets of nist compliant policies
such as geofencing which prohibits
access to the site from outside of the
us
content is accessed through google's
content distribution network taking
advantage of caching wherever possible
and finally to manage the cycle of the
infrastructure a terraform script is
used which is an open source tool and is
structured into five folder environments
can you share a bit more about what was
the experience like for users before and
after the virtual career center was
launched sure so
in a sense the solution that we built it
changes the way job seekers interact
with the state in the state agency i
mean before the virtual career center
you know interested people there there
was a website and there were website
resources that people would utilize but
it was very much in many states uh you
know a hodgepodge of things that the
training opportunities there was often a
state database of jobs that they could
search into and it was some very basic
online capabilities but a lot of things
happen physically in the career center
you know there's a lot of that
face-to-face interaction where you know
coaches could really have an impact and
help job seekers
and the challenge when we built the
virtual career center is how can we keep
that intimacy how can we keep that
collaborative nature and how can we
dial up the online tools in a sense
because in many respects we were forced
to but try to keep that that tight
interaction we strive to keep that
personal interaction and like to say now
a job coach can talk to a job seeker on
opposite ends of the state and they can
really focus on getting the right advice
the right coach in front of the right
job seeker it's exciting to me to see
how we can continue to recreate these
safe spaces in a virtual format and on
top of that create better alignment
between job coaches and job seekers who
have expertise in navigating different
services this is thanks to having more
robust ways for job seekers to find
coaches with specific backgrounds such
as coaches who have a history with
helping college students and joel is
there a fun fact
you could share with us about the
project well i can share one interesting
fact we
before we launched the solution with
rhode island which was the initial
virtual career center uh state that we
we uh we deployed him we were a little
concerned about the adoption from the
career coaches you know they were
already having to deal with working from
home
we showed them what it was going to be
like
we we tried to everything we could to
ease them into it and we did it with
sort of holding our breath you know
what's going to come of this
uh we were actually pleasantly surprised
they were absolutely uh excited for the
solution they were commenting how it's
really going to help them out they
couldn't wait they were asking how soon
they can get it so it was kind of
interesting i think we were overly not
pessimistic we're more concerned of what
the reactions would be but they just
embraced it wholeheartedly and were very
excited it got us very excited that uh
you know we are doing the right thing
we've created the right experience and
just seeing them absolutely pounce on
the solution was it was very gratifying
yeah i think that fear of whether a new
tool is going to be well received or not
especially amongst so much change in the
environment is extremely relatable to it
practitioners and so your approach is an
excellent example of how important it is
to scope time to collect user feedback
and to do it very early on and as often
as possible when designing systems
another topic i want to touch upon is
data by having more data centralized in
a digital format there are greater
opportunities around analytics and
insights what were some design
considerations with data working a lot
with data in the virtual career center
solution in particular we're looking at
analytics right if we're going to
implement a solution like this key
stakeholders in the state right up to
the governor's offices they want to know
is it working are people finding jobs
are people having career sessions so
there's a lot of analytics to track
what's working and not working and we
can do this in a virtualized solution
and we talk a lot about creating
analytics and dashboards not just for
stakeholders within the state who are
interested in how the virtual career
center is doing but we talk a lot about
employers because a lot of times
employers are posting jobs and want to
use those virtual career centers to
connect to job seekers so we're talking
about an employer dashboard so they can
understand who's out there who who's the
positive candidate pool and how can they
see how the job center uh the virtual
career center can benefit them and we
even talk about personal dashboards do
you envision any technical enhancements
in the future to this architecture and
is this solution only for state and
local entities so the virtual career
center or the vcc as we call it it's
actually comprised of three pillars this
way we talk about it one is around
modernizing digital experiences and this
is taking what is for many states a an
older design older set of technologies
that they used for very basic online
functionality and giving that all a new
modern look a modern face a central
place for people to go for all their
needs and requirements as a job seeker
within the state so that's the
modernizing the second pillar is around
new innovations can we bring machine
learning and artificial intelligence to
job searches can we help with resume
building or resume parsing where i can
actually take keywords out of a resume
and match those to certain jobs
more of in a clustering machine learning
model rather than just a raw keyword
search we also looked at chat bots and
the ability to take some of the load off
the call centers and states and
utilizing natural language processing to
help guide job seekers and answer
questions so and we looked at a number
of those types of innovations the third
pillar in the virtual career center is
around taking what was a brick and
mortar physical career center and
putting that online and doing it
virtually using google meet and other
technologies to create a virtual version
of what was happening in those physical
career centers so far every state we've
talked to they tend to choose different
things it's interesting because you
think they all need the same
you know have the same needs but
their own history their technology
uh savviness the needs of their
constituents it tends to vary and so we
find different commissioner stakeholders
different states
you know they need different pieces and
that's why it's nice to be able to put
out a we almost call it the menu we tell
states you can order off the menu and
depending what you order you know
obviously they have prices just like a
menu and so that's how we work through
budgets and solutions with them and it's
been interesting to see different states
so beyond just state governments we've
actually had some interesting
opportunities to talk about the virtual
career center and the technologies and
the solution with some counties with
some other uh
other countries and a number of
universities you know everywhere you've
got people looking for jobs or people
looking for additional training or
looking to you know better their careers
there's an opportunity in the virtual
career center well thank you joel for
walking us through so much great
information about your journey today
to wrap up and leave on a positive note
what was a memorable moment you
experienced
one of the things that i have said is
you know throughout the pandemic i think
for me personally and i think for a lot
of the team
uh
you know we're not front line workers
we're not health care workers we're not
grocery store workers and you know we
were kind fell along for the ride in
some respects during this whole thing
and so being able to be part of a
solution that is doing our part i mean
we may be on the i.t side of it but just
being able to
you know do something in our field to
help people's lives get better to help
people find jobs coming out of the
pandemic get a job that maybe they lost
to the pandemic it really felt like you
know doing our part versus being on the
sidelines through this whole crisis
ah yes this work is quite meaningful and
i think it's an epic milestone to be
able to scale operations to a virtual
format in this way which speaks to the
beauty of building in the cloud and
designing for a positive user experience
well friends i left several helpful
links in this video's description in
case you want to check them out if you
like this type of content then feel free
to watch more episodes on architecting
in google cloud or subscribe to the
channel
cheers
[Music]
you